[Music]
all right hey everybody welcome back to
the what podcast i'm barry over there is
taco and we have a special guest
david grimes good to see you again man
yeah nice to see everyone yeah we'll get
into uh why you're here in a little bit
uh just want to bring everybody up to
speed
brad you'll notice is not here which
is typically a good thing uh but i don't
want to knock a man
uh
i don't ever like to make fun of
somebody over something they can't help
and
if you guys watched the last episode you
know that brad and hillary are moving
from new orleans to new york
which i don't wish
moving on anybody i don't like moving
across the street
across town i can't imagine
what they're going through and if you
remember we had a discussion with jeff
cuellar
uh who was also moving from california
to atlanta and we were talking about
some of the horrors of
moving and moving companies and
sure enough it happened to brad so uh
he's had to scramble and therefore is
kind of busy uh but um
we had promised to show this week
with uh our winner uh from our uh
contest
and that's why david grimes is here
congratulations
yeah thank you so much that was awesome
it's a lot of fun to do well we'll get
in
a lot of great work that came through
yeah there really was and i wanted to
talk about that and um
kind of jump all over because that's how
i do things and that's how my brain
works but uh
i want to start and uh
david you've been listening to the show
for since the beginning does it go back
2018 was it when it all started wow yeah
yeah
yeah that was the first year david uh
was one of our patrons
uh it has been on the show before i was
looking um thanks to the wonderful work
of lord taco in our website which is
what i want to talk about here in a
minute
uh but uh was able to look david you
were on with the
lark and po episode
yeah 2020 i think it was
um
yeah i think being the one of the
patreon members got you on so you did a
couple interviews with uh that's right
some of us all right my hope that was
the plan anyway um
i i think we got to all of them
eventually yeah well let's uh like i
said i want to jump around and since i
mentioned the website
we don't really talk about that as much
as we should and
uh
russ is completely uh responsible for
that and if you haven't looked at it in
a while it's pretty doggone awesome um
really easy to navigate and it's got uh
everything from the lists of guests that
we've had the topics to uh
merchandise
um
believe it or not we have some merch uh
which if you guys are interested i'd
love for you to get some because it's
sitting in my basement and uh i'm tired
of tripping over it
uh happily got rid of some of it just
this morning as a matter of fact
go ahead and tell you guys that like
david who participated in the contest uh
you you there's a care package on the
way yep that's that's right there's a
there's a
lovely parting gifts for all of you so
thank you all for doing it uh we'll get
into that some more but uh russ i i'm
doing all the talking you designed the
website you're the one that
created it and i've been bragging on it
all morning to you and anybody else
that'll listen but uh
what
tell us about it
so the website like the show itself it's
evolved and taken on a new direction
because you know when we first started
this show uh it was really just to talk
about the artists
you know because we didn't we didn't
know who they were so we just decided to
deep dive into each one
and then nick turner the
fellow camp nut butter uh person there
he designed the logo and the the color
scheme and the layout and everything
and he he drew on a piece of paper
like what he thought the website should
look like and he handed it to me and it
was like
three rectangles
[Laughter]
and i'm like
how am i supposed to make a website out
of this so you know i did the best i
could but um you know we've kind of
transitioned the show over into more of
a deep dive on you know
the people behind the scenes and you
know how the sausage is made all that
stuff so
i've kind of uh evolved the website a
bit to make it more you know to bring
all that stuff more to the front make it
easier to find uh the shows because
we've got
115 episodes or something now like yeah
there's a lot so you know keeping it all
categorized and organized and
presentable
that was my goal so hopefully it uh
looks a lot better and works a lot
better now
yeah i mean that's why i wanted to talk
about it i mean it like the show
when we
when we conceived the idea it was
supposed to last about two and a half
months and here we are five years later
and
100 and whatever you said and we've
talked to some amazing people that we
never in the world you know imagine that
we would talk to and
and honestly i've enjoyed talking to
people like david as much as i have you
know
some of the singers and stars that we've
had because
that's the amazing thing to me david the
fact that you've been around all this
time like us it's just
it says so much about festival doesn't
it bonnaroo and festivals in general
that we can talk about it all year long
it does and
the what's just become part of that
experience i just love you know when
first are in 2018 it was like that build
up and
you had the interviews and you talked
about you know what to pack what not to
pack first timers and stuff and it was
just like that whole experience that
that kind of on ramp onto it and so i
just stuck around because now it's just
just part of the experience of manure
now now just last like you said all year
yeah it's crazy to think that uh
i mean people like you i mean i i feel
like i know you i do know you or you
know it's uh there's all kinds of people
russ
has talked about he runs into people
because he gets out of the house more as
as we all know but uh
but i mean brad actually sent me a
picture
i guess you saw it too russ he sent a
picture of somebody you ran into down in
new orleans this past weekend that
listens to the show and
that's amazing it's so cool and uh
it means everything but
like i said we'll get into the the
contest thing but david you mentioned
uh what to bring and all that kind of
stuff because
what was your first year going
i went back um
it all blends together right before i
think two years before the pandemic
so that 2018 going into it where um i
got to see uh
muse and eminem and all them
okay yeah 2018 was my first year too so
i i remember it well
all right yeah it does all blend
together and and i have to be honest not
only
does it blend together but the last
couple of years it's almost like i'm
having to reboot it's been so long
you know i was thinking about it this
morning it had gotten to the point where
the whole year had a rhythm
you know it was all focused towards june
and bonnaroo
and uh and january when the lineup you
know i mean it really had developed this
rhythm and there's been
not like we hit a pause button i don't
know what kind of button we hit but uh
it's got me all messed up so
um what are the things
you're going now especially since you
got tickets um
what are what is the veteran david how
are you different 2022 planning for this
company yeah well
28. it's uh
i said i have to reboot except to start
remembering all the all the tricks and
tips that that we received over the
years but
um i'll always go back to one and again
i hate to give brad props so i don't
give too many but i love we love the
carpet idea just like goofy stuff that
we hear about and like actually kind of
was nice you know um for us it was not
bringing so much food because you never
got around to it we were always busy
doing stuff and like you didn't want to
bring the grill and stuff at the same
time i know there's people who bring it
and they cook awesome things so you know
if you're if you want to bring it bring
it but if you're on the fence you know
like we were we didn't we didn't pack
too much and it was great and it forced
us to you know
pack lighter on the food and go out to
all the different vendors and
and experience that so that was really
nice and i think for that tent because
it's it's baking yeah just as you get
shade and if you cool as much as
possible in that in that tennessee sun
um i mean by the time that sun you know
gets up you're out 10-10 minutes after
sunrise so
yeah yeah there's no sleeping once the
sun
no no sleeping once the sun comes up
what are you what are your thoughts um
because we have to remind ourselves brad
and i do and i know russ even because
you know it's been you've been to two or
three but
you know i think in our minds sometimes
we still think it's 2005 2007. you know
we still have that little thought in our
head comparing and i we have to keep
reminding ourselves that when we go this
year
you know about half or more than half
will be new uh that's typical new patron
new no new guest so could be even more
than that because of the the change and
we haven't been on the farm no one's
been on the farm in three years so
[Music]
you know what i mean it's hard to it may
be like starting over maybe some of the
i would think the carpet is still going
to be a thing you know things like that
but uh
are you thinking about that at all and
then i have a
another reason for asking the question
definitely i i think that was like the
coolest part about our first bonnaroo
with my wife and i going it was
you build it up in your head so much and
it was exactly if not more than what we
anticipated and thought of and dreamt of
and stuff and it was awesome and and for
us you know the music is a big part of
it but it was just
the whole package really you know from
meeting everybody and everybody's so
cool no matter you know age or your
background or whatever it is your taste
of music everyone was just super cool it
was like this little utopian place that
you know that's like a sci-fi thing but
it was you know our experience everybody
was so cool when to each other
um our our neighbors on each side of us
were super cool and we were so different
but we just all got along and enjoyed
our time together you know at the tent
and the campgrounds and
um
just experiencing all the different
things that they got going on uh on on
the farm was just was great so we look
forward to
getting that kind of 360 full experience
again in addition to into the music
the fun part is for 11
months and three weeks to
go over your schedule you know like you
do a final four or you know or whatever
else
and then yeah just throw it up if you've
never been the farm is 700 acres it's
huge
it's hot there's so much going on you
know you think you're gonna
jump from one stage to the next and
you're gonna be able to see everybody oh
and you get tired let's don't forget
that you get tired
your feet hurt
but just having so many choices now
i'm really curious to see
what that does to me
and everybody else you know that idea
that you can try to see as much as you
want and see everything and then
you just can't it's just not physically
possible
yeah i think it's hard to break a
routine too so i might have to like
make myself not do what i usually do
when you go there and actually try to
explore new things and and force myself
that might be a fun way to approach it i
think
yeah like i said i think we'll get into
it when brad's back taco and i because i
wanna we could probably do two or three
shows on this there are parts of the
farm i've never been in uh you know
there are stages i've never seen
uh just for whatever reason and uh
we've never we never ventured out into
the you know gaa
until a year or two ago with the the
beer exchange
but there's so much going on now that
like i said you could literally spend
your whole time there and just be happy
well and hopefully they have that
they've announced the jam track train
system hopefully that makes it easier to
get back and forth around the different
campgrounds and stuff yeah i'm hoping
it's not just one guy in a bicycle or
something i hope it could carry a lot of
people
i'm sure it will
all right well let's talk about uh the
contest david again congratulations and
we got a lot of really neat clever uh
uh entries and
i i mean i just go ahead and say david
yours won because it had so many
different details in it i mean it looks
professional is it do you do this kind
of thing for a living
a little bit i uh i uh i design uh
online courses so that that involves
some graphic work and
and using photoshop and stuff like that
so yeah that's where my
my kind of
my expertise trends but um
i think
there are so many cool
uh entries in there between i mean what
got me was what made me really do it was
because i laughed so hard when i saw
joshua's
microsoft paint type drawing with with
like tacos the beer can
it was awesome
i'm glad you brought that up because i'm
looking at the page with everybody and
and i want to make sure
i
say this right i mean say it
you didn't win because yours is the most
professional looking uh in my you know
mine because i love that one too and
you know i love my hair i mean that's
just
glowing and jaunty
i'm like you i laughed and and you know
that was that was just as much a
contender
as yours i i um
just the detail though of of yours the
you know the pbr cans and the ruham with
uh parker and
you know yeah throwing in the rooham
park
give a shout out
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah it just ticks so many different
boxes um
yeah all of these were super yeah
they're a lot of fun
i i
it did sway me a little bit you know the
the one that you did and a lot of them
i'm really skinny and uh that that was
that was really
important look brad said
yeah
and you got brad you know i don't know
what that move is but it's hilarious
yeah you can you could tell looking at
it that you've you know you've been to
bonnaroo and you listened to the show i
think that's kind of what was
um
i don't know important to me i guess
um
but yeah these were a lot of fun
um
i'm just looking scrolling through yeah
there's the high five
uh
yeah i mean
yeah it's pretty amazing we have we have
so many different mediums here i mean
you know you've got the microsoft paint
and you've got obviously some digital
ones and then you've got somebody
actually physically got out you know a
pad and paper and looks like they drew
it with colored pencils and stuff and
then we also had a video submission yeah
yeah it's it was a lot of fun
yeah it was so so much so and seriously
like i said i sent packages to everybody
all you guys so you'll be getting uh
something and that um hopefully this
week or soon uh because of it it was uh
it was a lot of fun just looking at them
and
one thing i did notice that i
i wanted to mention uh and forgive me
all of you guys that get a package my
handwriting is horrible
does anybody have to write anymore i
mean you know i'm a journalist so i type
but uh
if you can't read
i'm sorry they were i've got wadded up
pieces of paper where i started to write
something and i couldn't even read it so
i just thought
[Laughter]
well congratulations it's uh you you
you'll have two tickets uh with park i
mean with camping
yeah yeah and brad will have to get you
uh the details on how to make that work
um
and can't wait to see you so
yeah russ anything else
i think that about covers it so yeah
thank you so much for uh for your
submission and glad to see you again
glad to have you back on
oh thank you no i appreciate it
yeah well i didn't i didn't ask earlier
i should you're you're in ohio right for
people you're probably wondering uh so
you'll be making that trip how long's
the drive
oh it's uh forget it it was like eight
or in some hours last time when we drove
down we stopped once on the way so i
kind of messed me up but
it's a it's a nice day trip all the way
just driving we usually come in a day
early and
we stopped by the um last time we came
down a day early uh we had vip so we
came down wednesday and stayed at the
hotels like across the street so we were
just right there and we just hopped on
over real quick on thursday which was
really nice so we might do something
like that again
yeah that reminds me you reminded me of
another question i wanted to ask when
are you coming that's another detail
that we haven't really explored
uh atlanta yeah
i haven't really thought about it that's
a good question
i see those tuesday people and god bless
them but
i don't know i i might just do the
wednesday or thursday again i i know um
i know rue buses have an event on
wednesday night and stuff so that's kind
of i might want to attend that thing and
they are they are okay good
and then uh so i might just do the
wednesday thursday again have a routine
down but i would love i don't know if
it's like vegas where if i came down
tuesday it would be like too many days
in a row and be there
exactly where like vegas is about three
or four days i'm okay and then it's time
to head on out i'm sort of that way at
the beach i'm like all right i've done
it been there yeah i know russ is
planning on going tuesday and he would
go a week a week before tuesday if he
could
i would leave right now if i could yeah
yeah i'm i'm not sure
you know i've stayed
through sunday
it
the last three or four for me it used to
be thursday morning
and i would leave
sunday morning
and then
started staying sunday night which i'm
glad i did i never should have left that
day but there were reasons and then they
started having a media day on wednesday
so it became wednesday through monday
and that's a pretty long slog
i mean it it's a long week i don't care
who you are and now to add a tuesday
i don't man that's
it's a you got to really think about it
because you know we talk about uh
don't go hard
you know pace yourself it's not a sprint
that's right yeah and you know the
inclination i don't care you know we did
it last year we got there wednesday and
went too hard
wednesday night and it makes it makes
thursday
okay but friday is a long day if you do
it if you go too hard early
well now we've gone you know almost
three years without being there so it's
going to be difficult not to go hard
because exactly i just haven't done it
in so long exactly well
we'll figure it out and there are worse
problems to have right
at least we're at least we'll be there
so
all right well david thank you so much
taco good to see you glad you're feeling
better
thank you very much and uh we i don't
know if we'll be back next week with
brad hopefully we'll be back with
something but like i said
i don't wish what he's going through on
anybody and uh oh i know
hopefully he gets all settled in in his
new job and new house and all that so
if not we'll we'll get through it i
think we're what under 70 days now
75 was last i heard maybe a day or two
ago so yeah we're closing in on three
months
well david thanks again and thanks to
everybody else who participated in our
contest and
look forward to seeing everybody
[Music]
[Music]
consequence podcast network